[MUSIC PLAYING]
MILES WARD: Hi, everybody.
My name's Miles Ward.
I'm the global head of solutions
for Google's Cloud Platform.
And what that means is I
help people adopt the cloud,
move to the cloud.
I have an incredible privilege
to introduce a friend of mine
that I did not
help move to cloud.
They did it all on their own.
And as a result,
they really know
all of the wrinkles
and the hard steps
that it takes to
figure this out.
And the results that
they've received
are absolutely incredible.
So I can't wait for
Nils Pommerien, who
is the senior engineering
manager for Nest,
to explain to you how
they've moved to cloud.
Are you excited about that?
Sounds good?
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
NILS POMMERIEN: Perfect,
thank you, Miles.
This is pretty amazing.
You guys are comfortable?
Perfect.
Last time I've been this far
in front of a movie theater
was like the premiere of
"Titanic" or something.
That's a long time ago.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Nils Pommerien,
as Miles said.
I'm leading SRE at Nest.
And I'm very excited to
share with you our story how
we migrated onto Google Cloud.
Real quick poll, who here
has migrated to Google Cloud
recently over the
last couple of years?
And I see one hand.
It's really hard to see.
A couple of hands, perfect.
Who here is planning on
moving to Google Cloud?
That's even more
hands, so perfect.
That's great.
So let's see how
this works, next.
Just to set the
stage, I just wanted
to share the numbers and
the scale of the service
that we are operating
to support Nest cameras.
Has anybody here-- and I'm
going to keep this casual.
Does anybody here have
a Nest camera at home?
A lot of people, very cool.
Thank you, first of all.
So it's really massive.
And we were facing a
challenge really on two axes.
Number one is just the
sheer size and the scale.
So we are operating on
hundreds of thousands of cores.
We're recording tens
of petabytes of data.
And the data just keeps coming
at like hundreds of gigabits
per second.
So that's obviously
number one, getting
that amount of compute and
data over into the cloud,
or into Google Cloud.
The other one comes just
with the service requirement
and the customer promise
that we're making.
So as you know, as customers,
we're recording 24/7.
And we're doing so, and the
customer expects zero skips
in their timeline so they can
go back to any particular event.
The other one is that we
make a customer a promise
that they at any given
time can open the app
and actually check in on their
video footage, and all of that
in millisecond latency.
So, that's what we had to
move, pretty big service,
certainly the biggest
service I've ever worked on.
Let's go back a little bit.
Where did we come from?
So about four years ago,
pretty much exactly four years
ago, Dropcam was bought by Nest.
And Dropcam really has
been the foundation of what
is known as Nest Cam today.
And then six months prior
to that, Google bought Nest.
So that brings up
the obvious question,
did they make you do this?
Did they make you move
onto Google Cloud?
And I want to debunk that
because it would actually
cut the talk in half because
we talk about our decision
process.
So the short answer is no.
Up until recently, we're
an Alphabet company.
And we call them "other bets."
And as a bet, you really
make your own decisions.
And it's also fair to say
there's good parts of Nest that
continue to run on AWS.
And there's other
bets that are not
on GCP that are also either
self-hosted or in other cloud
providers.
So the decision process
that we're talking through
is completely self-made.
So where were we?
About four years ago, Nest was
already a pretty big place.
We had thermostats,
smoke detectors.
We had cameras.
Since then, we've added more
cameras, more thermostats,
security system, et
cetera, et cetera.
Today, I really want
to focus on the camera
side of the business.
And the camera in
AWS was built--
or the camera service was
built with AWS components
such as EC2, S3, DynamoDB, and
then for analytics, Redshift
and Kinesis.
I like to use the analogy
of a box of LEGOs.
Each cloud provider has
their own kind of tiles.
And some of them
are very compatible.
So if you compare S3 to
Google Cloud Storage,
they fit very well together.
But then there's other
services, such as DynamoDB
that you have something like
that in the Google Cloud box,
but you actually need to
adjust your build quite a bit
to create the same
customer experience.
So that's what I'm going
to walk you through,
how we found replacement
technologies for all of these.
The other thing I wanted
to say real quick, as we
were acquired, much
smaller operations.
We were operating
on tens of gigabits
of recording, which was
the equivalent of hundreds
of years per day.
Today, we record in the
thousands of years every day
of video.
We're running on
hundreds of servers.
And they were still
scaled fairly manually.
They were provisioned
automatically through Puppet
and Cloudyn, and so
forth, but definitely
less mature than we are today.
But then the Nest acquisition
was a great opportunity.
And it really
supercharged the demands
on our cloud infrastructure.
So number one, Nest already
had a foothold in Europe.
And we needed to follow suit.
So very quickly, we had
to move our operations
into a global operation.
The second one, Nest allowed
customers on newer cameras
to turn the sensors
from 720p to 1080p.
And with all the
image recognition
and so forth that we're
doing, that actually
means we need to operate
on about twice the amount
of pixels.
And last but not least,
we have constantly--
over the last four
years, we have constantly
improved our vision
algorithms to actually send
meaningful events
to our customers.
So that also caused a
significant increase
in just compute demand.
So we are faced with a decision.
What are we going to do?
And let's talk through
how we ended up
deciding to go to Google Cloud.
So without a doubt
probably for us,
the biggest reason
was Google global--
the global nature of Google's
network and its components.
So for our service,
all the video
is obviously recorded
in the cloud.
But then the video
that is live viewed
is actually being
reflected off the cloud.
So as such, it's
actually fairly easy
to understand the closer you get
that compute to the customer,
the better the experience
is going to be,
the lower the latencies
are going to be.
So as we enter new markets,
it's really important for us
to have a presence
as close as possible.
So Google Cloud helps there.
And we'll look into
that in a second.
So building in
multi-region story
in cloud, whether you do it
for just proximity like us,
or regulatory reasons,
or quote, unquote
"just to achieve resiliency,"
it just seems very easy--
or from experience,
it's very easy
to do it with Google Cloud.
So that was one.
The other one was savings.
So if you run a business,
you're obviously
worried about operating costs.
You're worried about margins.
One cost that we are
tracking is the services cost
of operating a camera.
This is real numbers
without the actual values.
But this is how we have seen
the cost of operating a camera
decline over time.
Now, I do want to say it's
highly dependent on your use
case.
So in our use case, we actually
stripped everything apart.
Enterprise agreements,
RIs, we just
stripped that apart,
looked at street pricing.
Compare that to
Google Cloud pricing.
And with that alone,
we've seen a 20% decrease
in operating cost.
Now in real numbers, that
means tens of millions
of dollars for us.
And that's just in one
year, very, very massive.
And obviously our finance
team is excited about it.
But we are too because
what it actually allows us
to do it's fund new features.
So we are building
additional features.
And some of the features that
you see on the cameras today
have been funded through those
kind of cost-down efforts
that we'll continue to drive.
So Google Cloud really
helped us there as well.
So let's take a look at
the migration approach.
So in a nutshell, this
is what it looks like.
And I really was hoping
this was a smaller
room so I can show up here.
But I have a laser pointer.
Cameras stream into the cloud.
From there, video
is recorded into S3
and video metadata along with
any event that we have detected
goes into DynamoDB, great.
And then the client, whether you
use your browser or your phone,
rendezvous on the same server.
And you can consume the stream
or watch a recorded video.
Now when we started off, we
sat down with the Google Cloud
folks and we were like,
hey, couldn't we just
move that S3 thing down
into Google Cloud Storage?
It's a great idea.
But the way all
public cloud pricing
models work, it's like all
your inbound bandwidth is free.
But outbound isn't.
So it would have been
really cost prohibitive
to do any hairpin turn in AWS
just to store it into GCP.
So what we had to do
instead it's really built up
the entire stack in
Google Cloud and build
the necessary abstractions for
a server that is in Google Cloud
to know to talk to Google
Cloud Storage, and to Spanner,
respectively, as a replacement
for S3 and DynamoDB.
So that took a while.
But it was the way to go.
And then the actual
migration became trivial.
So we updated the
database record, said
you now belong to Google Cloud.
And we could do this
one camera at a time,
which is really important.
You now belong to Google Cloud.
We sent the camera
disconnect signal.
The camera dials back in.
It connects to Google Cloud and
starts recording over there.
Easy, we're done.
This works extremely well,
by the way, for new cameras.
But what about the cameras
that have been recording
and have data recorded?
Assume they're on a
10-day recording plan.
So what we wanted to
avoid is a big copy job
because ultimately it would
have still been egress charges.
And also if you imagine,
as many of you are users,
not all the video you have ever
recorded you actually look at.
It's a small
fraction of the video
that we ever actually play back.
And on top of that, the data
is actually self-expiring.
So after 10 days, we have a
customer promise that we're
going to delete that data.
So what we build is a technology
called [INAUDIBLE] gathering.
So if a client
requests video now
connected to Google Cloud
that is still stored in AWS,
we just pull that in
automatically across clouds,
stitch it back together, and
present it through the API
as if it would be
all in Google Cloud.
Now, it's very specific
to our use case,
but what's interesting here is--
what's interesting
here is you can
do this with any application.
Even if you have
S3 log processing
and the data is
expiring over there,
you can easily use public
cloud APIs securely
over the internet.
Bringing back the
LEGO analogy, there's
no reason why you
can't intermingle
those different services.
So it was a breakthrough
moment for us
to really keep migration
costs under control.
Next, I want to
talk about the how
we build a global architecture.
So to do that, I want to
talk through real quick how
a camera first connects.
When you first
power it up, it goes
through this routing
lookup layer where,
backed by load balancer, that--
backed by a load balancer,
which, in turn, is backed
by Compute Engine instances.
And we do a quick
lookup figuring out
where this camera
belongs and then
actually connect this camera
straight to the owning server
of that camera.
Now very quickly, you can
add a couple of regions.
And now really try to
look at both ends of this,
whether it's the load
balancer on the left side,
with a couple of
API calls or clicks,
you can add compute
engines from any region
really to that load balancer.
And if you look at it
from the right side
as well, whether it's
the global Spanner
storage or within a geographic
region, a Google Cloud Storage
bucket, all these things, and
other services that are not
showing, such as Pub/Sub,
just are global in nature,
making it very easy to build
a global infrastructure.
The other thing that's important
here, and it's not shown,
is it's really the
same VPC network,
it's the same firewalls,
it's the same public APIs
that we've called, and
the same public API
endpoints to launch
these instances.
It's really just a
matter of specifying
the launch region of where
you launch your instance.
And last but not
least, all of them
are connected through
Google's fast backbone.
So even if you have
cross-region traffic,
you're don't to have to deal
with VPC peering or anything
like it.
It just works.
Next, we can just add
an entire continent.
So going into Europe, for
example, going into Asia next,
now it's very
cookie cutter to go
into new markets
and new regions.
And SRE or operations
is now no longer
in the way of the business
to enter new markets, which
is really a great enabler.
Yeah, that's how we build
a global architecture.
There's three takeaways I think
that I want to talk about.
And the first one is
focus on reusable tools.
So doing a migration like
this is a huge investment.
So in our case, we've written
thousands of lines of codes.
And at every step and every
turn, we've asked ourselves,
is this a one-time deal,
or is this something
we could actually
reuse in the future?
So remember [INAUDIBLE]
gathering, how we brought
things from AWS on-demand over?
So imagine whether
it's a future feature
or something we do automatic
as part of like a DR strategy
or so.
But let's imagine we're moving
a camera from the US to Europe.
Why wouldn't we want to
use [INAUDIBLE] gathering
that we've now once built
to pull in data on demand
from other regions if we have
to and then stitch it together
and present it back?
Imagine a camera
or an owner moving
taking the camera with it.
You can take it as
far as, in the future,
sensing of where that
camera is best connected.
So again, it's just one
example of re-usability.
It's something that we
really, really focus
on during this migration.
My next favorite topic is to
think outside of the Ops box.
This is probably the
most important thing
that I learned during
this migration.
So I run SRE.
And I was tasked with
getting the service over
to Google Cloud.
But my lesson here is whether
you're SRE, PE, DevOps,
NetOps, make it known
within your organization
that this is really a
cross-functional exercise.
And if you do it well, and you
really focus on the customer,
you can really build
a seamless experience
or make the migration
extremely seamless.
And you actually end up or
possibly-- and I'll show that--
in a better place
than you were before.
So I want to show
two quick examples.
Number one is for the
live viewing case.
So if you do this poorly,
you can easily get to a point
where, OK, we
migrate the camera.
First of all, we try to
avoid migrating a camera
while it's actively
being viewed.
But let's assume for a second
you migrate a camera while it's
actively being viewed.
You move it over, send
the disconnect signal,
it comes back in.
If a customer is viewing
this camera feed,
it turns black, customer
has to exit the app,
go back in, and so forth.
It's frustrating.
So we work very closely
with the apps developers
to say, hey, if we
send you a signal
that we just changed regions,
can you just reestablish
a spinner for a second?
And that's effectively
what we did.
But it actually now
improves the resiliency
and our communications signaling
between the apps and cloud.
So it's one example.
The other one is around
the recording model.
So the cameras-- and this
is something where we worked
with the [INAUDIBLE] team.
Again, we own end-to-end
of the communication.
So we worked with
the [INAUDIBLE] team.
And we used something
we call backfill.
So the camera in itself has
a little two-minute buffer.
So when we send the
disconnect signal
to come back into Google
Cloud, it's five seconds.
On the other side
in Google Cloud,
the camera will negotiate
with the service
to say, hey, where
did you left off
recording over in AWS or
anywhere else for that matter?
And then we are negotiating
and stitching the timeline
back together.
So as a result, if you come back
later that day and your camera
had been migrated,
you absolutely
see no seams on your timeline,
which is pretty neat.
So again, it took a lot
of effort to get there.
But it's like, we were that
concerned about the customer
experience during
this migration.
And then the other thing
is re-architecting.
And do it often.
If I would have
waited, or we would
have waited for Google
Cloud to provide us
with a replica of
what we had in Amazon,
we would have never moved.
So you do need to adapt.
And if you look at the
marketing material,
very often what I
found is it scratches
the surface of what the actual
performance characteristics are
of their services.
And even if you look
things like S3 and GCS,
they're ever so
subtly different.
So as you go down
this road, I encourage
you to stay very nimble
and really embrace that,
that you need to
make changes a lot.
So here's a very
simple example that you
can wrap your head around.
So the average recording node in
AWS looked something like that.
So we are using
c3 instance types.
And we really like
them because they
come for free with these
awesome ephemeral drives,
super high IOPS, two times 80
gig, we strap them together.
And we use them
both to spool video
before we flush it out to S3.
But we also use it to keep
a cache of recent video
so we don't actually
have to retrieve it
from S3 every time a
customer requests something.
Now we're like, OK, so we
can build the same thing over
in Compute Engine.
So we were like, oh, let's
take an n1-standard-8.
Comes to a 30 gig of RAM,
really very similar performance
characteristics.
And we plugged a hard
drive in, a PD 160 gigs.
And we're like, oh, this
is going to be great.
It worked phenomenally
while in QA.
But once we actually put it
in-- like load under it--
load tested it, turns out--
and it's not the fault of PD--
we just like, it doesn't
match the I/O capacity
of a ephemeral SSD drive.
So we're like, OK,
that doesn't work.
So next, Google has a similar--
and this is why I'm saying both
of them check the checkmarks.
They have ephemeral drives.
Google has a drive that's
375 gigs local SSD.
It's S volatile.
It's S fast.
The problem is
though, it's too big.
It's the smallest
denominator that you
can attach in local SSD.
For most customers,
it's not a problem
because they actually
attach 10 or so of them
to run big Cassandra nodes.
But in our case, if you operate
thousands of these servers,
it would have just
been a giant waste.
So we ruled that out as well.
And then we started
thinking, let's
take a look at the 160 gigs and
see what we actually used them
for.
So we added instrumentation
around your cache hit rates,
or cache miss
rates, and so forth.
And it turns out we actually
didn't need all that storage.
So we ended up with
a machine-- and this
was all in a matter of
a week or so, so again,
staying very, very nimble.
We ended up with a machine
that was an n1-himem-8.
That's how it's called.
So it just comes
with more memory.
And we carved up
to 25 megabytes--
sorry, 25 gigabyte hard drive.
And it's S volatile
as a local SSD.
It has even better
IOPS performance.
And in the process, we
saved a bunch of money
as well because we
didn't have to attach
all these additional drives.
So it's that kind of thing where
once the rubber hits the road,
you really need to make
adjustments, and embrace
that, and be open to that.
So great.
So takeaways.
This ties back into
the hard drive story.
Don't be afraid to experiment.
My number one advice is invest
in good instrumentation.
You want to set the
baseline of what
the customer expects is
experiencing in your old cloud
provider.
And then you really want to say
with confidence whether you're
moving the needle in
the right direction
or in the wrong direction.
The other thing I feel
fairly strongly about
is forklifts don't work.
You don't want to
come in on a Monday
and change DNS of
your entire service.
I really try to move either
one customer at a time.
In our case, it didn't work
due to data constraints.
But if you can, one
service at a time,
have a fallback
strategy, and so forth.
We did that more
than once where we--
in the early phases where
we moved a couple of cameras
over and then we moved them
back, internal cameras.
And then as I said before, it's
like hitting six right numbers
in the lottery, you're
not going to pick
the right infrastructure
on the get go.
So really, I encourage you
to stay nimble and actually
embrace that fact to make
changes often and see
if you move the needle
in one way or the other.
That's one.
The other one is
focus on reusability.
So I said before, it's not
SRE, PE, DevOps problem alone.
Really try to focus
on the customer.
And you do have an opportunity,
just as I showed you to,
actually come out with a
service and a platform that
is better and more stable than
it was before you actually went
down on this journey to migrate
to cloud or to Google Cloud.
And last but not least, save
money and have fun with it.
It's something that we do.
It's in our DNA to constantly
create additional headroom
for features.
And we've just scratched
the surface on it.
I mean, sustained use
discounts, you get for free.
But then Google has great
knobs to really drive
your operational costs down.
So we are looking very
heavily into autoscaling.
And we're very excited
about preemptible VMs
in particular for
some of our workloads
to reduce costs even further.
[MUSIC PLAYING]